ein deal mit libyen sie kriegen geld und
sperren flüchtlinge werk ende problem
den staat lybien den gibt's gar nicht
mehr
die sogenannte regierung beherrscht ein
gebiet ungefähr in der größe dieses
waschlappen ja der rest ist bürgerkrieg
und blanke horror wir schon mal leicht
nach brüssel zu christian ehring
christian können wir als eu angesichts
solcher deals wie mit libyen wirklich
auf die usa herunter gucken aber
selbstverständlich kann wir dass wir
sind europäer
sie sind von natur aus die guten deshalb
wurde hier gerade erst das brandneue
europäische zentrum für moralische
überlegenheit eröffnet wir verachten sie
anführen widerlichen ein eisiger für
ihre ekelhafte bauer
unser weg ist kooperation und
partnerschaft und wir glauben nicht an
mauern und an vermute genau glauben wir
die mauern und zäune sind das
hinterletzte deswegen haben wir keine
gut jetzt bis auf diesen riesen showdown
mit der spanischen exklave melilla in
marokko der mit den ganzen afrikanern
oben und natürlich den in der anderen
spanischen exklave deinen vater ja
logisch aber sonst sicher vielleicht
könnte man noch den an der griechischen
mazedonischen grenze erwähnen den
zwischen bulgarien und der türkei und
den in ungarn
natürlich das ist ja eh klar also gut ja
wir haben schon freunde aber wir glauben
dich ran dann der unterschied amerikaner
diese amerikaner sind fit faschisten wie
mit mir das jetzt noch mal erklären ich
bin einen kleinen widerspruch deutsche
diplomaten sagen meldung aus dieser
woche in libyschen flüchtlingslagern
herrschen und ich zitiere kz ähnliche
zustände und trotzdem wieder in zukunft
die flüchtlinge hinschicken
ja ich verstehe die frage nicht
so ist jetzt der zeitgeist alles was
nervt bremen nach nordafrika flüchtlinge
nerven ab nach nordafrika warum ich auch
die ganzen arbeitslosen jungen griechen
die zehn euro war darauf los die
stimmung unter angeblich hatte merkel
sogar kurz überlegt teile der csu
nach libyen haben natürlich die video
das lassen wir sie war da natürlich via
direct eine obergrenze eingeführt wird
erschwert da müsste man sagen da ist der
tramp im grunde ehrlicher könnte sich
frau merkel nicht auch hinstellen und
offen sagen vogel leute mitleid ist alle
ab jetzt heißt es für zu feiern
das könnte man wenn man doof ich meine
wir wollen ja beides keine flüchtlinge
und moralische überlegenheit
außerdem müssen wir da noch das tolle
neue merkel denkt mal hier in brüssel
wieder abreißen sogar der es enthüllt
worden
götz in europa auf dem ganz hohen räume
und für dieses teure denkmal lassen wir
übrigens die amerikaner bezahlen oder
mexiko das entscheiden wir noch
natürlich
[Applaus]